okay i can tell you now the breaking
news is that british airways workers
have voted yes to strike action 95 said
yes and there was an 81 turnout so the
inevitable strike action looks like it
potentially will go ahead there will be
a few meetings between now and whatever
proposed date is put forward by the
unions most likely they will target the
summer holidays so possibly the end of
july and into august they want maximum
disruption of course but they say don't
blame the workers blame british airways
their dispute is over at 10 pay cut that
british airways check-in staff and
ground staff here at heathrow had during
the pandemic which is yet to be
reinstated they argue that bosses at
british airways have had their 10
percent pay cut reinstated to
pre-covered levels and they want the
same they say it's not fair in fact they
are described as being furious at this
um now this was a formal ballot there
was a consultative ballot a few weeks
ago which basically
the result was the same thing this is
formal and it gives the unions the legal
right to forge ahead to put in place
everything that needs to be to go ahead
with uh that strike action the unions
have described universal discontent
across the workforce here um they have
said that what you know the context to
the working conditions here not only do
they have a 10
pay cut in comparison some of their
other workers uh they are also facing
and have been facing can continue to
face at the worst verbal and physical
abuse that they've ever encountered
and they say uh partly um the airline is
to blame for that in many ways because
it failed to prepare
adequately to reopen up the industry uh
this is an industry-wide uh issue in
terms of the the uh challenges if you
like that heathrow airport has faced and
the airline has faced um and it's not
the first ballot that we've seen not the
first strike action that has been
announced in spain next month easyjet
staff will be going on strike um british
airways have said that they have offered
workers a 10 bonus that has been
rejected by workers who say that would
just be a one payment offer and that
potentially could mean they would waive
their rights to any future fight
on a pay rise in fact they don't like it
when people use the word pay rise
because they say it's not a pay rise
they were being paid this it was just
taken away from them and it hasn't been
given back but what we can expect
potentially although the unions say
they're open to talks with british
airways what we can expect is a lot of
disruption in the summer which will
further compound what we've been seeing
over the last few months not just here
at heathrow but across the other
airports as well you know we've seen
thousands of flight cancellations we've
seen lengthy queues and we've seen that
baggage mountain here at heathrow just a
few days ago so it's been chaotic and i
think we can expect that to continue
indeed well adele robinson thanks very
much indeed for getting us up to date
with that latest breaking news we
appreciate it so adele telling us there
the british airways workers based at
heathrow airport have voted in favor of
strikes in their dispute over pay i'm
sure there'll be plenty of reaction to
that throughout the day